Go back.
>> All right. Freeze. Don't move. Don't
move.
>> Okay. No pressure though.
Where is the deviation from yesterday's
training?
No, that that's not important. We didn't
even talk about that yesterday. Not so
important here.
Do you do you see that?
>> Do you see the angling? Okay, that the
shoulders are
this one's forward. Do you got it? Okay,
now why
there's something else?
He's He's obviously trying not to be
turned. Do you see that? So, he
contested against the turn that he felt.
Okay. Now, go to what's making him
turnable.
Because when we contest, we start the
whole rippling,
right? The pebble in the pond. Just as
we we have the non-contestation and it
ripples out, the contestation ripples
out, too. So, you're going to see uh
where this is being exacerbated by
something that had that he did from the
very start.
>> No. Come and look around the body.
What were the instructions yesterday?
Where's his elbow related to his
shoulder?
>> It's outside the shoulder. Do you see
that? And that generates
this
this. Do you see? So, let me in. See his
elbows out out here. And so I if if I
just push because I gripped on the
outside. I didn't grip here. Make a
fist. I'm not gripping here.
There has to be a slight Yes. But yes.
So you'll feel it now. You see? Okay.
And again, my coach should have just
been able to do that. But you what's
happening is when you're down, you feel
your own flexion
and you feel like you're doing
something.
You need to do as UK the same thing he's
doing. He is letting energy go down. I
let energy go down and that's what's
moving. And he could feel that shoulder
biting neck. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, so let's have another team go. I
don't care who go watch
down.
Okay, stop.
You see that? See the angle again? We're
already in the contestation. Do Do you
see that? Trying to get trying to get
here. Okay,
there's already
a weakness in the torso in the in the in
the spine. So, don't move. You don't
move. Now let go.
Do you see it?
>> Okay. So your first thing is you're
relax. You're relaxing,
right? But what were we told yesterday?
Releasing is not relaxing. I can't go
like this. What were we told in zen? My
spine has to do.
Reaching up. You can't. If you relax
it doesn't do it. So you have no energy
going through your spine. Okay. And
which you can expose. Okay. All right.
So my point here is that all these
things are showing up but I'm just not
conscious of them. Just like I'm not
conscious of the habitual flexion I have
all day against the gravity that's
working on me. You see? And I never feel
the rebounding force or the pressing up
of the earth. I never feel those forces.
Okay? But imagine in your art
that's one with the universe. We're
supposed to be able to feel those
forces. And if I can feel them, I can
use them. You see, and that's where and
if I can use them, then I don't have to
use these other forces that make me
waste energy and things like that. Okay?
So, let's all get to a conscious level
so we can answer the question again.
Where's my flexion? Okay.